For B of 0, I just plug 0 for t into our function. Since e to the 0 is 1, you
just have 1000 times 1 or a 1000. This is what we would expect, since this is a
starting value of the number bacteria. And, as we just calculated, it's the
value when t equals 0. We're off to great start. Plugging in 1 for t, we end up
with 1000 times e to the negative point 5. My calculator tells me 606.53, and
I'll round that to 607. So after 1 hour has passed, almost 400 bacteria have
died. Plugging in 2 for t gives us an exponent of negative 1. My calculator
tells me that's about 367.87, rounding a bit already. Which if we round to the
nearest integer gives us 368. After another hour only 220 more bacteria have
died. But that makes sense when we look at the graph over here. We can tell
that as we move further to the right the graph is getting less steep. So it's
less steep between the values of t 1 and 2 than it is between 0 and 1.